hey guys Pete here this will be a
breakdown of the official Watchmen
episode 3 promo the title of episode 3
is she was killed by space junk and this
teaser looks to be scenes that all come
from the upcoming episode rather than
the end the weeks ahead format that we
got after episode 1 I'm gonna break this
down scene by scene talk about how it
connects to things from other trailers
that are already out there and speculate
about what it all means this breakdown
will contain spoilers for everything
that's happened in the first two
episodes and everything that has shown
up in official trailers from HBO it will
also contain spoilers from the original
Watchmen comic series and details from
the official PD files supplemental
information website that they put up
after the breakdown I'll go into
speculation and theories that may be
more spoilery but I'll give you a second
warning if you want to avoid those the
episode 3 trailer opens with the Lord of
the Country Manor he's preparing to mr.
Phillips this guy's wearing a strange
helmet and suit for something he says
are you ready to venture into the great
beyond and when I hear the term the
great beyond
I get afterlife vibes things are not
looking good for this guy whether he has
a suit on or not he has a rope tied
around his waist which made me think of
this catapult looking device that we saw
before but I can't tell you why he would
want to fling him or why he would put
him in this suit we'll have to wait and
see because the only thing that this
confirms is that the Jeremy Irons scenes
are going to continue to be weird
there's a jet with the United States of
America painted on the side that comes
into frame inside of it we get our first
look at Special Agent Dale PD who we
know from the supplemental website that
bears his name
Agent P DS in the FBI and he works for
the anti-vigilante task force research
unit and he's headed to Tulsa we know
this because he's looking out the window
at the Giant yet unknown structure that
dominates the Tulsa skyline in this
alternate reality he says look on my
works ye mighty and despair which is a
line from a poem by shelley titled
Ozymandias at the cemetery people are
arriving for the chief's funeral there's
a handful of people with signs out front
but you can't read any of them I assumed
in the check for the guy holding the
future as bright sign that we saw in
episode 1 but he's not there the casket
is being carried by uniformed officers
complete with their masks
Jane Crawford and Senator Joe Keene are
following it
cuts to a shot of keen talking to the
press after dark he has blood on his
collar and says I promise to defend us
from all enemies foreign and domestic
this interview will probably make more
sense with what we see later as well the
7k guy emerging from a tunnel with a
duffel bag this was in a prior trailer
and I had zero guesses of where this
could be taking place it's followed by a
close-up of the suicide vest next to
what looks like the same bag and that's
followed by someone wearing the best
what's a Deadman switch in their hand
after that there's an interior shot with
Angela presumably talking to Laurie
saying we should be prepared there are a
couple shots of the pod and lookingglass
going inside of it this looks like the
aftermath of the roundup at Nixon bill
Red Scare throws a prisoner out of the
back of a police transport vehicle with
pirate Jenny there with him Laurie
approaches them and introduces herself a
special agent Laurie Blake this is
outside the building where they keep the
pod and we've seen more of this
conversation in previous trailers and
the longer version Laurie sets up the
prisoner by asking if his civil rights
have been violated and then sort of
makes a joke that she doesn't care the
lord of the manor rides his steed past
the black freighter looking Jolly Roger
flag that's attached to a side inside
his castle he grabs a cake with three
candles on it from Miss Cruikshank's and
throws it on the floor the number of
candles on the cake matches the episode
numbers which is interesting the obvious
explanation is that each of these scenes
exists a year after the last anniversary
but really how could we know for sure we
go inside the dr. Manhattan looking
booths we've seen Laurie walking out of
this in a previous trailer and here we
see her talking into a phone on the
inside she says God snaps his fingers
and the hero goes to hell I have no idea
where the saying comes from if I'm just
making wild guesses God sounds like dr.
Manhattan and the hero sounds like
Ozymandias this booth has been a mystery
since they first introduced it it looks
like a phone for contacting dr.
Manhattan and Laurie being his ex-lover
would probably be a good person to do
that but still does a direct line to dr.
Manhattan make any kind of sense at the
funeral there's a shot of Laurie plenty
a gun behind Angela as she turns
probably aiming at a 7th cavalry member
whose car
the party that's followed by a look at
the keyboard for the Manhattan Machine
there's a lot of buttons on it I can't
say anything else beyond that in a
really curious shot senator Keene opens
a birdcage cover to reveal an owl inside
Laurie's boyfriend after dr. Manhattan
was fond of owls is it Keynes owl
there's a theory going around about this
which I'll discuss later after the
breakdown in the spoilers section from
that owl we transitioned to Angela
wearing the night owl looking glasses
coming out of the same tunnel the 7 keg
I was using earlier my guess here is
that she's investigating things after
the funeral we see Laurie in the pod
with Looking Glass she hits the button
and Rorschach inkblots appear on the
walls in case you've forgotten Laurie is
the one person we know of in the present
timeline who knew Rorschach then we have
this costume character jumping from the
balcony in the bank what's going on here
is another mystery to me we've seen more
of it in previous trailers looks like a
flashback
looks like Laurie shoots this guy she is
in the room as far as I know but who he
is and when this is isn't clear after
that angela is running from the coffin
towards Laurie who has her gun drawn no
one else is in the shot except for a
police officer off in the distance
then the coffin goes boom we see it from
above and there doesn't appear to be any
mistaken that the coffin at the center
of the funeral explodes no one looks to
be in harm's way so Angela running away
is probably right before this happens
feels like all the 7th Kay suicide vests
stuff could be related to this but there
isn't any direct evidence in these last
two shots there's definitely not a
suicide bomber that we can see if the
Chiefs body was in the coffin that's
going to be mighty traumatic for his
family and all the police officers that
served under him and that is where the
trailer ends so what do we have special
agent Laurie Blake will arrive on the
scene in Tulsa probably accompanying
agent P D in that jet we saw
lookingglass and the other cops will be
interviewing the Nixon Ville residents
trying to learn who was behind juds
hanging things we'll move over to the
funeral where the 7th cavalry will
likely stage a second attack while
that's unfolding we'll take a trip to
check in on the blond man at the manor
get a better idea of who Lori is in
flashbacks and possibly learn more about
senator keen from the weeks ahead
trailer I expected that we would get an
introduction to lady true but she
doesn't appear in this trailer at all
she could be introduced in this episode
but it's starting to feel like episode 4
is where we're gonna get filled in on
her story now I'm gonna talk about
spoilers I haven't seen past episode 2
but some critics have been given up -
episode 6 full review they've written
about that without giving too much away
I haven't read any direct spoilers but I
think we can connect some dots based on
what's out there
if you don't like to hear information
like that now is the time to leave
please like the video if you enjoyed it
and subscribe so that you can come back
from our episode and trailer breakdowns
from what I gathered I expect this
episode to fill us in on Lori's
backstory we've learned from the PD
files that she was arrested with night
Isle - in 1995 for violating the Keene
Act and that she now works as an FBI
agent we don't know what happened in
between those years though so I think
this episode will start to fill in the
blanks that could help make sense of her
going into the blue booth and it could
even give us some idea of why that owl
shows up in the cage the theory about
the owl that's out there is that Senator
Kean is the secret costumed adventurer
night owl the third it's hard to say and
it's hard to see how we get to that from
where we're at right now but that
doesn't mean it isn't possible based on
interviews and reviews I expect episode
5 to be the looking-glass backstory what
we'll probably find out that he was
present during the squid attack in New
York City
I think the carnival scenes are probably
related to that but that isn't really
important for the upcoming episode my
gut is telling me that we won't really
start to understand what's happening
with Ozymandias until after that happens
Lindelof has vaguely mentioned that the
two stories were on a collision course
and it feels like everything has to be
set up in Tulsa with all the characters
there before that can happen
my guess right now is that we'll get
insight to lady true in episode 4 since
her corporation bought updates companies
which is important and she's a complete
wildcard at this time so that would be
like Laurie episode 3 lady true episode
4 Looking Glass episode 5 until we get
back stories for LG and Lady T it's hard
to commit to any big picture theories in
my opinion there's so much going on and
I think the writers know how people will
break down every clue which gives them
the Opera
tunity to use that to their advantage
case in point is the early theory that
chief Judd was going to turn out to be
night out to the show seems aware that
once fans found out gene Smart was Silk
Spectre they would look for her
counterpart there are clues that make
you think it could be possible that it
could be Judd but it didn't turn out to
be the case I think this goes for
everything that we see and we have to be
careful the idea that will Reeves is
hooded justice this is a good idea and a
well supported theory I totally
understand why people believe it but I
don't think we can overlook the fact
that the show's creators would know that
putting him in the same colors would
lead to this exact theory it doesn't
mean that he won't turn out to be hooded
justice and I feel like there would have
to be a reason for them to give it up so
easy in this case I think he'll be
connected to hooded justice and in turn
connected to the origins of costume
adventures but I think there's going to
be more to the story there's a lot of
theories about where Ozymandias is and
what he's up to people think he's being
imprisoned by dr. Manhattan some
theories go further to say he's on Mars
in prison by dr. Manhattan I'm not
completely sold on that idea there's
also an idea that he's trying to create
his own dr. Manhattan from the clones
but again not a lot of direct evidence
to go off of at the end of the story dr.
Manhattan wasn't interested in human
affairs and he didn't see Adrian bate as
a threat to this point we don't have
anything to convince us that he's
changed his stance we do have that blue
dr. Manhattan looking booth we do see
Laurie talking to the phone saying God
snaps his fingers and we do have the
24-hour feed where he's supposedly on
Mars but there's no solid evidence that
he's come back in contact with humanity
beyond those kinds of things
Ozzy is somewhere that isn't 2019 Tulsa
though and he's got a bunch of clones at
his disposal while the clones seem
high-tech everything else around the
Manor does not any time we see tools
they look to be of the antique hand
bride we just can't tell what's going on
there by design the episode 5
description does say that the smartest
man in the world plans a daring escape
which would indicate that he's in prison
but at this point I don't think we can
say for sure that it's dr. Manhattan who
put him there or where this prison is at
the same time it feels like what he's
doing there might have an effect on the
current timeline in Tulsa or if not then
he probably is trying to get dr. Mann
his attention after all would it be a
continuation of the Watchmen with no dr.
Manhattan involvement in the outcome
we'll have to wait and see let me know
in the comments what you think about
this trailer for Watchmen season 1
episode 3 what series are you following
what series do you like which ones do
you think are gonna happen where do you
think things are heading please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching guys I will
talk to you soon